tras aterrizar en el aeropuerto de goma
el primer grupo de unos 900 soldados
kenianos es recibido por militares y
dignatarios congoleños
las fuerzas tendrán su base en la
provincia de kibú norte de la república
democrática del Congo para ayudar al
ejército congoleño a luchar contra el
grupo Rebelde m23
las instrucciones de los jefes de estado
pero también los conceptos son muy
claros
nuestros amigos kenianos están aquí en
una misión puramente ofensiva
las tropas kenianas forman parte de un
contingente mayor que se espera de la
comunidad de África Oriental en abril el
bloque de siete naciones acordó
establecer una fuerza conjunta para
restaurar la paz en el país un
comandante keniano dijo que su misión
también ayudaría a las personas
desplazadas por la violencia
la inseguridad es algo que rompe el
tejido social y requiere asistencia con
la población local por lo tanto
trabajaremos junto con las agencias
humanitarias hacia la realización de la
paz y la estabilidad dentro de goma
el m-23 se formó en 2012 capturando
brevemente la capital de la provincia
coma antes de ser expulsado tras años de
inactividad los combatientes volvieron a
tomar las armas el año pasado reclamando
que el gobierno no cumplió con la
promesa de integrarlos en el ejército
este año se han apoderado franjas de
territorio incluida la estratégica
ciudad de bunagana en la frontera con
uganda según la ONU los recientes
combates entre el ejército y el m23 han
desplazado a unas 188 mil personas